السابع عشر من اغسطس عام
1994 يشارك زين الدين زيدان ابن الثانيه
والعشرين المره الاولى مع منتخب فرنسا في
الشوط الثاني امام تشيك يسجل هدفه الاول
بعد دقيقه ولا يحتفل حيث لا يزال الديوك
مطالبين بهدف اخر لمعادله النتيجه بعد
دقيقتين فقط يتلقى الشاب الصغير زيدان
عرضيه ويضربها براسه في الزاويه العليا
لتسكن الشباك هنا يدرك الجمهور ان هناك
مونديال عام
1998 وبعد عامين يفوز بافضل لاعب في امم
اوروبا 2000 بعد احراز بلاده اللقب في
رائع لكنه يخسر النهائي الا انه يتصدر
العناوين وذلك الشهيره للمدافع متراثي
صانع الالعاب السحريه اعتزل الكره القدم
وبعد عقد من الزمان يتولى زمام الامور في
مدريد يتوج باحد عشر لقبا ويثبت انه ضمن
الافضل لاعبا ومدربا